okay well from hollywood to vegas beauty
queens are taking the stage again for
national pageant and this one's not for
all the single ladies okay
we're bringing so vegas back celebrating
women's history month with an inside
look on becoming
mrs nevada america and hopefully on
march 27th
mrs america now live
from convention hall in atlantic city
the miss
america pageant the lights the
excitement
the entertainment the stage itself it's
it's historic it's iconic and
that's why our state pageant uh costume
is that of the show girl from showgirls
to beauty queens
vegas has no shortage of glitz glam
feathers and crowns and whether you're a
miss or
mrs you can roll the dice this is the
premiere pageant for married women
taking her first walk as mrs nevada
america 2020.
ashley tesoro wife mom actress model
and philanthropist ashley tesoro is
ready to take the stage for the mrs
america
national pageant naturally doing the mrs
nevada america pageant
was the perfect opportunity for me
because not only do we get to be on
stage and
do all this glamour and beauty and
fashion but we are also
workers in our community for doing
amazing outreach
and doing benevolent works and working
with charities and so for me
it was the perfect fit i have a
seven-year-old
i have a five-year-old i have a
two-year-old so
naturally i'm you know working all the
time being a mother being a wife and i
really think that the pageant has that
element of doing something just for you
and whether you win or you don't win
it's really not about that it's about
the journey
but we want to win so what does that
take
welcome to beauty queen boot camp take
your right foot
and step forward do this slowly as
you're looking over your shoulder
sure you need poise and poses i'm
working on that
but what you don't need is perfection
it's not about the
perfect image it's really about being
the best version of yourself
and i really believe that the paget
brings that out of every woman that gets
involved
and if you want to walk the walk you got
to talk the talk
interview is very important so when
you're presenting yourself to the judges
it's
super important so you really want to
work with somebody that knows how to
formulate help you formulate these
amazing answers that are authentic to
you but that will
translate to the judges so you know you
don't want to be too long-winded you
want to be able to be concise
that's a tip learned from former beauty
queen and state director of the pageant
jackie mckenna so get in your position
look at your judges back and forth
she'll definitely have you ready for the
judges well
we get five judges from across
the country they are from all walks of
life so they'll have different
perspectives
they look for the all-rounded woman who
can
represent everybody from across the
state it doesn't
matter if you are six feet tall or
411 we've had queens from all across
you know the range of of looks
ethnicities
walks of life doctors pilots
homemakers hairdressers or hosts and
reporters
jackie says the mrs nevada america
pageant is all about what you bring to
the table
and if that comes from the heart well
then the crown
is for you you got your crown on lindsay
oh well oh thank you thank you like
a pageant queen model about that i'll
leave that to ashley i'll leave that to
ashley oh my
gosh i mean you can catch ashley i know
we'll chat about it we'll chat about it
you can catch ashley at the live on the
live stream of the mrs america national
pageant
on the 27th and you can actually help
her automatically move into the top 15
of the competition by voting in the
fabulous face section
at mrsamerica.com